avez vous remarqué le taux directeur de
la banque du canada baisse et trois fois
au cours du dernier mois mais les taux
d'intérêt hypothécaires n'ont pas
diminué
pourquoi on ne nous offre pas un taux
hypothécaire plus bas la banque du
canada base son taux directeur pour
relancer l'économie
et normalement les institutions
financières suivent la banque du canada
et abaissent leurs taux d'emprunt au
même rythme d'ailleurs elle emprunte
elle même à la banque du canada
mais nous ne sommes pas dans une
situation normale le marché est instable
et difficile à prévoir pour les
hypothèques à taux fixe
si les institutions financières offrent
un taux d'intérêt bas pour cinq ans sans
savoir à combien elles vont emprunter
dans les prochaines années
c'est plus risqué ajoutez à cela que les
banques et les caisses empruntent aussi
à l'international
alors les hypothèques à taux fixe ne
baisseront probablement pas
prochainement
heureusement le taux d'intérêt plutôt
bas par contre pour les hypothèques à
taux variable
là c'est différent si la banque du
canada baisse son taux directeur
on va vous offrir un taux d'intérêt plus
bas pour une hypothèque à taux variable
en sachant que si dans les prochaines
années
la banque du canada augmente son taux
votre banque ou votre caisse va pouvoir
monter le vôtre c'est donc moins risqué
pour les institutions financières comme
toujours avant de prendre une hypothèque
comparer et négocier